une nouvelle mascotte est arrivé et
l'amour ou l'amitié va encore frapper
cet art quand deux personnes saines ce
soit d'amour ou d'amitié
ces deux personnes ont envie de se
retrouver même si le passé écorche le
futur 1 ou le présent est toujours là
ces poches que je dis allez voir de me
regarder comme ça ah non mais je sais
pas où tu vas raison est toujours là on
remettre les pendules à l'heure et faire
que deux personnes se retrouvent même si
tous les s'opposent père fouras les
morse romoeren 10,7 un panda envoient
leurs annonces oui premier indice la
première a dit que représente pour vous
l'expression loin des yeux loin du coeur
bonne soirée oh là où la castaldi est ce
que ça vous dit quelque chose
là tout de suite franchement non loin
des yeux loin du coeur tu arrives à
quelle heure tôt pour le prime je suis
arrivé en bas et session début
d'émission ouais ça là bas mais c'est la
sécession mais dany boon est ce que t'as
pas vu depuis longtemps mais naim a
priori non mais là il rêve de voir ça
[Rires]
quelqu'un d'amour d'un métier
je ne peux pas te le dire pour le moment
david sèchement benhaim je te garde pour
l'instant jean michel maire ça y est
[Applaudissements]
c'est fatou qui le rappelle pour lui
dire si elle veut bien reprend dans
l'épisode saint valentin
attention allô allô fatou wii qui est à
l'appareil à l'eau cette époque
allô allô oui c'est pas tout et oui
fatou à l'eau et l'huile mon chéri oui
c'est fatou dentelle une renault
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais ta numéro de fatou m'a menti
ah bah écoutes je voulais vraiment
prendre a fait pour la saint valentin va
merci lindt un amour chéri et on attend
des nouvelles de fatou je voulais
surtout te dire est que qu'il ne se
fasse pas
ville partout les vocations est là tu
vois intelligent rien dit car il est
généreux et moi je suis fan c'est celui
que je préfère chez toi oh merci les
drones au versus les années il a bien
sûr connu vial folie que gmail
il sera avec moi la semaine prochaine
via sur la grosse rigolade et fait le
jeu
gerry et moi c'est moi te gens râlent
fils aussi gbagbo dit non je suis juste
alphil merde oui il faut qu'il faut
toujours croire vaches et il y croit
jusqu'à 23 heures parce qu'après on a
mis ses morts jetait dans ma chair et
avec quoi la semaine prochaine c'est
très dur je t'aime toi tu es génial
c'est mal
c'est toujours frustrant
gilles est en train d'apprendre que
demain il va faire un tour à 3 que line
renaud il nous donne notre castaldi et
jean michel à la main
on n'est pas il est heureusement tu as
très bonne cote très bon animateur merci
mais bechiri alors regardez le deuxième
indice est ce que vous pensez que c'est
une bonne idée d'envoyer ses petites
culottes un fan alors si on a des
petites culottes ça vous concerne
elle en remet pas est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un vous avez pas vu depuis
longtemps plein de gens mais acquise en
ligne sur mac y as tu as envoyé une
gaine où une couche alors qu'on sait que
c'est bon
non pas que ce soit fanny qui le bizarre
que tu as déjà envoyer ta petite culotte
jamais est-ce que tu emportes et parce
que le prix next up on s'en vante a bien
fait le bus territoire fabien les reçus
mais j'en ai pas envoyer vos intérêts
fabien qui est le seul mec quand même
avoir un site plus grand que son pote
est sorti
[Applaudissements]
paul ii soit des culottes
ce deuxième en fin de deuxième indice
concernés valérie benaïm valérie bénaïm
écrit ja vous dit rien une histoire de
petite culotte avoue beinheim mais naim
non attends ouais non médaille c'est que
j'ai eu à j'ai eu un fan très insistants
mais naïm qui ment qui me demandait de
lui avec des petites culottes
ça a changé mais n'aime pas changer
benhaim merci fanni a laissé la vie a
travaillé il ya toujours des dépenses
pour la maintenance et à la fin c'était
j'avais la safege été acheté à fun radio
à l'époque d'accord y'a quelqu'un je
n'ai pas vu depuis longtemps
tu me stresse je te jure je cours c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai pas vu depuis
longtemps
oui ça prouve que tebbaneh bénard radio
je ne sais pas
un homme
c'est une femme beinheim est ce que
votre prénom votre surnom à l'époque
c'était toof tatum et où je vais faire
plier toof n'ya qu'une personne
je sais qu'il sait maintenant elle était
une personne qui m'a appelé comme ça
c'est poupe puisque les abus sexuels
avaient tout fait pour toi
on sait que ces pousses qui est dans le
panda est sûre c'est pour ça que j'ai
déjà et nous dire qui et pouf dans un
instant on n'est pas revue puis comme un
tampon ça fait 50 g par des proof fait 5
ans et vous avez vous êtes toujours vous
avez toujours une touffe ça va aller
c'est ça vous pensez que c'est tout
fuchs et pouf annoncé moi tout ça à
coeur
donc la bouffe et la barre et madame
pouf la wii est donc là tout fait ici la
poupée l'appareil on sait que la poupée
la poche venez rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
là bas pour y remédier un match à vannes
alors c'est ma peau ma peau à tendance à
faire sur ma poule attention ma peau
attention ma p'tite bouffe à torsion à
temps c'est une bonne idée ce discours
est bon cependant ce que pouf
c'est bon vous avez oublié pour flécher
bon push c'est bon pour yamaha poupe ça
m'inquiète parce que si tu es vraiment
pouf
alors coup de en était on est très amis
sommes pas vus depuis voilà à magalas et
on a on a vécu beaucoup de choses j'ai
parfois c'est vrai qu'elle est beaucoup
parti à huy est bien mais comment elle
s'appelle pouf
bah si c'est elle c'est camille camille
famille vous appelez famille du
journaliste
oui
[Applaudissements]
oui ça me venaient lakamy merci d'être
là c'est un amour est j'avais eu chaud
un petit peu alors valérie benaïm site
est votre meilleur ami faut expliquer
que camille est une immense journaliste
je sais grands tours nice à cela on
l'appelle poupe mais c'est une image
j'avais tout partager un bureau des
poils de chien ouais des fous rires
elle a même été votre témoin de mariage
oui hélas et un mois j'ai été témoin de
mariage utile aux mais il ya eu un petit
souci c'est quoi l écart est en retard
comme j'arrivais en retard ce n'était
pas de ma faute enfin sur sa non c'était
le pressing qui m'a rendu mon costume de
mariage magnifique avec taches jaunes
sauf que je m'en suis rendu compte au
dernier moment et donc je ne pouvais pas
trouver d'autres robes puisque j'avais
accouché peu de temps avant il n'y avait
rien qui m'allait donc c'est pour ça que
j'arrivais en retraite arrive en sabots
vous appeliez tout fait pour vous
appeler bouffe en baisse parce que
j'avais des cheveux comme ça elle se
trouve donc voilà on voit des opéras et
spectacles
voilà c'est on a on a partagé beaucoup
de choses beaucoup de joie beaucoup de
pas mal de larmes aussi des moments plus
compliqués et et voilà et elle sera
toujours dans mon coeur mais grave
termine très très tard qu'elle est là un
boulot aussi très très prenant vous
faites quoi
rédactrice en chef des eagles sadorn
d'orsay mission mais j'espère bien on
est fous si mu sur ça cartonne en plus
on a dans la voix la voix que vous
entendez dans le gall m6 c'est camille
sée vous camille mais c'est tout le
monde va dire sommaire ce soir à
chatillon maintenant tout le monde va
dire quand ils vont entendre dimension
audio mais regarde maman ses poufs
ceci dit les noms d'oiseaux fusent
toujours au bureau c'est un problème et
on a envie qu'on vous revoyez un peu
tout les doigts oui toile et après tout
on se fait un déjeuner parce que venir
ici pour pouvoir te voir si le radar on
la famille depuis famille merci
merci beaucoup
les fans l'audio